so we get to look at some viral Tick
Tock videos oh
here we go again we've got a woman
talking to her baby and trying to
communicate some ideas to the baby that
might be over his head a little bit but
I don't know let's see what
you may not touch my belly button that's
my body and I don't want you to touch it
that way
yeah you may touch your own belly button
but I do not want my belly button to be
touched okay yes I am in charge of my
body and you are in charge of your body
and right now I don't want my body to be
touched on my belly button yeah okay so
you you can touch your belly button
because that's your body but I don't
want my body to be touched right now
yes okay
oh really do you want your bottle
yeah I'm sure your six month old baby
can understand what the hell you're
babbling about I'm sure that's really
sinking in
your lesson about uh about consent is
seeking in with your with your infant
child and also how just weird is it to
frame this as a matter of consent your
baby is touching you and you're framing
that as him violating your consent your
baby that's how you want to like see
this that's that's the sort of the the
the framing the context we're giving
this yes mother do I have consent to
make physical contact with your mother
six month old supposed to say that to
you that's what you're expecting people
are such freaks absolute Freaks and I
see I feel so bad for these kids I can
only imagine what's going to happen as
that child gets older I take my kids to
protest because I want them to learn to
use their privilege for justice I let
them wear what they want and go to drag
queen story hours because Love Is Love
All Humans are valid and gender is a
social construct I ask if they want hugs
because I need them to know that they
have consent and control over their
bodies and that no wings no I teach them
about racism and skin color because they
are not too young to learn I never force
them to finish their plates because I
want them to have a healthy relationship
with you I have them tell me their
feelings by showing me inside out
figurines because sometimes that's
easier than putting emotions into words
and I teach them to love everyone
because life is too short for hate
uh I mean
this this is becoming a it seems like an
increasingly popular because I'm seeing
on social media more and more this thing
about you don't want to force your kid
to eat because you want them to have a
healthy relationship with food I guess
the idea is that if you force your kid
to eat that you're going to cause like
eating disorders down the line no that's
not what it's about
there's a few things making your kid eat
the food that's on their plate eat the
food it's about teaching them not to be
wasteful which is a very important
skill you put food on a plate and the
kid doesn't eat it and then you just
throw it away let me ask you is that a
healthy relationship with food to throw
good food away
when they're starving people out there
is that a healthy relationship no you
make them eat it because it is uh it's
about not being wasteful it's also about
being grateful
okay you are providing sustenance to
your child you're making meals for them
you're doing all that and uh even though
it's your responsibility as a parent
they should still be grateful that
you're doing it and refusing to eat the
food is uh is not grateful and also
because you do have to force your child
to engage in proper nutrition because if
you don't if you let them take the lead
all they're ever going to do is they're
just going to be eating pure sugar like
if you let your kid decide that if you
had if you had a jar of sugar you know
in your pantry they will just eat from
that like sugar and wash it down with
soda that's all they'll eat
why is that because kids don't know
what's best for them kids will also be
hungry
and yet
they'll want to refuse to eat anyway
even like they want to eat and they need
to eat and yet they'll try to refuse
anyway because they're being defiant or
because they're in a snit about this or
that Black Rifle coffee company is on a
mission to build a support network for
veterans First Responders and law
enforcement by serving you the best
coffee you've ever had thanks to your
support that dream has become a reality
this year alone Black Rifle coffee
donated over 120 000 bags of coffee to
Veterans and First Responders while
expanding their own team of active duty
service members veterans and Veteran
family members who worked for Black
Rifle coffee if you want to continue
supporting this incredible company go to
blackrafulcoffee.com use promo code wall
should check out for 10 off your
purchase and your first coffee Club
order Black Rifle coffee is roasted by a
veteran-led team of brilliant coffee
graders right here in the U.S the coffee
is truly one of a kind but it's your
support that gets gear funding and
supplies into the hands of those out on
the front lines go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code walls for
10 off you can also find Black Rifle
coffee in grocery and convenience stores
near you Black Rifle America's coffee
okay there's one more this one's this
one's kind of seeming again passed
around on uh on Twitter quite a bit and
this I believe is a woman talking about
her trans two-year-old if I'm not
mistaken let's watch some of this okay
so first of all I will say that the
process the journey is ongoing and
probably will be for potentially her
entire life but here's how it started so
she was designated assigned observed
male at Birth and until about 18 months
didn't really you know know too much
just kind of was raising two kids
working full-time not really paying
attention to what was going on and at
around 18 months started she started
showing signs of like really being
interested in things that her sister had
and had in her closet and wanting to
play dress up and wanting to put on lip
gloss and when she would see fingernails
she would want her fingernails painted
too and you know we just we thought it
was cute no issue we had no issue with
you know her wanting to do those kinds
of things and then around the age of two
things started to progress at a quicker
pace and so each time that we would go
to pick her up from preschool
she was fully outfitted in dresses and
Jewelry
and so I will say I was super stoked
that we had such a wonderful child care
center that she was in because she was
allowed to you know experiment with her
gender and play dress up and do those
kinds of things and have access to them
so when I would go to pick her up from
preschool like I said she would be
dripping in you know just jewelry and
clicky shoes and all kinds of stuff and
getting her to take that off to go home
was usually a pretty gnarly struggle uh
and then around the age of four she
started wanting to wear like leggings
and headbands she had this one headband
she was completely attached to that she
felt I I look back on it now and think
to myself gosh I wonder when she put
that that headband on she thought to
herself people see me for who I am No
One's Gonna misgender me now
um and so it progressed it just kept
moving in that direction with more and
more things that started showing more
and more signs she would say when I wake
up tomorrow I'll be a girl and we were
kind of like oh okay yeah and my husband
and I would be like we gotta we gotta
figure this thing out and so kind of for
that final test my husband decided you
know what we're gonna figure this thing
out we're gonna we're gonna tap into
this and see what happens so he said you
know I'm gonna coach a t-ball team and I
want her to be on it and so I was like
all right let's do it well that didn't
go over so well she not only hated
t-ball she hated the uniform she hated
the Hat oh okay everything in the trash
multiple times Well if you hated t-ball
then he must be a girl there's no other
explanation obviously
that was the final right that's when
they knew that was the final test
because there's no way a child could not
like t-ball unless they're a girl turns
out all my kids are girls because none
of my kids like t-ball even the kids are
playing t-ball don't like t-ball they're
just what they're not interested in it I
didn't like t-ball either that okay well
I guess I'm a woman then this is a weird
way to find out I didn't I never thought
I'd find out this way but you know
that's not the worst thing in the world
that means I can't be criticized anymore
I'm uh you know I I have more victim
points than I ever thought I did I have
so much contempt for uh these people the
parents are the worst she is an evil
despicable woman I will continue to say
with people like this should be in
prison life imprisonment you know and
I'm not satisfied with anything less
than that life in a cage for this
monstrous demon is what she is
because she wanted her child to be trans
and uh hell or high water she was gonna
get it because she wants her kid to be a
fashion accessory for her and she will
destroy her son's life to do it
that's what this is I know the more
charitable interpretation is that rather
than being a monstrous demon she's just
the dumbest
on the planet because that's the other
potential right I mean she's just so in
her and her her and her useless hen
pecked emasculated effeminate ballist
husband are two of the dumbest humans to
ever live that's the other possibility
because you would have to be that stupid
if you're one and a half year old son
shows interest in shiny pretty things
and so you start to think maybe he's
actually a girl and then your your
little tiny son says I'm going to wake
up as a girl tomorrow and their response
is well I don't know what gee I don't
know how to what to say about that
here's what you say to that oh no you're
not son you'll you'll be a boy tomorrow
because you're a boy end of conversation
that's it that's all you got to say so
ish are they really so stupid that they
don't understand that or are they evil
and they are creating this identity
crisis in their poor helpless son
because
um it will make them feel better and
they convert your signal and make Tick
Tock videos like this I guess it's up to
interpretation I can't see inside their
hearts or their souls I especially can't
see inside their souls because I don't
think they have them uh but I think
ultimately you know uh I I just don't
think anyone is that stupid I just don't
I don't believe it so we're going to end
on uh that fun note as always
[Music]